c'est à présent le procès des attentats
du 13 novembre 2015 s'ouvre aujourd'hui
à la cour d'assises spéciale de paris un
procès historique mais aussi très
sensible gérald darmanin appelé elle est
responsable de la sécurité du territoire
à la vigilance maximale pendant toute la
durée de ce procès le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a transmis son message
aux préfère regarder
notre vigilance collective doit être
totale tant à l'égard de la menace
terroriste endogène qui exogènes il faut
maintenir à un haut niveau de vigilance
tout particulièrement aux abords des
lieux de culte des lieux d'enseignement
de grands rassemblements dans un
contexte de retour à la normale et des
anciens lieux d'attentats vous
mobiliserez en conséquence les forces de
sécurité intérieure pour une présence
visible et dissuasive
un procès hors norme 130 journée
d'audience plus de 1800 parties civiles
330 avocat va accuser on va parler de ce
procès historique à la une sur notre
site rt france point tv avec notre
journaliste web antoine boitel
[Musique]
antoine bonjour alors dites nous qui
sont les accusés
bonjour olivier alors je vais pas vous
faire la litanie des vins accusé dans ce
procès
ce procès du siècle ainsi qu'on
l'appelle
cependant on peut retenir déjà qu'ils ne
la qu'un seul qui fait partie du à
proprement parler du commando qui sont
encore en vie le fameux salle abdeslam
qui est donc resté mutique depuis son
interpellation en mars 2016 en belgique
on peut aussi retenir que parmi les 20
accusés on en a quatre qui sont très
probablement morts décédés en zone irako
syrienne à la suite de frappes dont les
deux frères klinge à michel et fabien
qui a revendiqué les attaques du 13
novembre
un autre est incarcéré en turquie il est
retenu par la turquie après son
interpellation en nommant où il essayait
de passer ancien x et un dernier semble
donc encore en fuite en fait pendant des
vins alors on a aussi un certain nombre
de suspects qui comparaissent pour avoir
apporté principalement un soutien
logistique à la cellule jihadiste et on
en a même parmi eux quelques-uns qui
comparaissent libres sous simple
contrôle judiciaire et quelles sont les
spécificités
opérationnel de ce procès du siècle
bonjour magali alors les autorités
affirment ne pas avoir décelé de menace
vraiment envergure c'est à dire une
menace qui serait du même type une
cellule jihadiste
al craignent quand même des potentielles
attaques individuelles on a vu alors
ordonné à s'exprimer récemment à ce
sujet pendant le procès comme c'était ça
a été le cas pendant le procès a su delà
de l'attentât de charlie hebdo un
périmètre d sécuritaire strict a donc
été mis en place aux abords du palais il
a une note du préfet un arrêté
préfectoral en fait du préfet de police
de paris qui est passé le 3 septembre
on voit que il ya des zones interdites
au public sur l'île de la cité à des
zones soumises au contrôle d'identité
très stricte notamment évidemment plus
près du palais donc avec des entrées du
palais qui seront gardés et soumise à
des listes de noms de personnes et puis
il ya d'autres
qui sont interdites au trafic automobile
tout simplement la salle d'audience
spécialement construite dans la fameuse
salle des pas perdus elle a été conçue
pour recevoir 500 personnes dont ses
gigantesques en fait par rapport à une
salle d'audience normale et d'autres
salles ont été prévus pour la presse
d'un côté pour les parties civiles juste
à côté parce qu'en fait on dénombre pas
moins de 1800 parties civiles et 300
avocats qui viendront pour ce procès qui
se relaieront les uns après les autres
si vous vous laissez ces gigantesques et
tout le monde ne va pas venir mais c'est
quand même c'est noir effectivement le
procès du siècle il va durer neuf mois
et les observateurs s'accordent
globalement pour dire qu' il s'agira
pour la france de démontrer qu'elle est
capable de juger la barbarie terroriste
merci beaucoup antoine pour ces
précisions et et pour aller plus loin à
vos articles antoine boitel à lire sur
notre site arte france pointé vers